on saturday october 31st 2020
the family of legendary actor sean
connery shared the sad news that the
james bond actor had died at the age of
90.
james bond while the cause of death was
not immediately disclosed
it was revealed that he passed away in
his sleep in the bahamas after quote
being unwell for some time as reported
by the bbc
after connery officially retired from
acting in 2006
he largely stayed out of the limelight
and seemed to enjoy spending time with
his family in the bahamas where he made
his home
however his later years did include a
couple of major health scares
prior to his retirement connery
underwent treatment for throat cancer in
the 90s
then in march 2006 he had a tumor
removed from his kidney according to the
guardian
since then any news surrounding the
double 07 actor's health has been kept
private
but the family's statement suggests he
was dealing with undisclosed issues at
the time of his death
unless his family chooses to share the
exact cause of the actor's death at a
later date
fans may never know what health
struggles the actor went through in his
final years
but what's most important is that his
retirement years were happy ones for
connery
who enjoyed golfing and spending time
with his second wife artist micheline
rockbroon despite being one of the most
recognizable actors in the world
connery managed to pull off the
impossible in his golden years
he lived a private life after he and
rock broon made their home in the
bahamas
the actor rarely made public appearances
he did make a rare
appearance in august 2017 at new york's
us open tennis tournament
at the time he appeared happy to have
his face shown on the screen at the game
as double 07's famous theme played
according to usa today
in terms of acting connery's final
live-action role was in the 2003 feature
the league of extraordinary gentlemen
her majesty's government is willing to
offer you
amnesty in retirement
for your services at the time he
revealed that the filming experience
soured him on hollywood as a whole
connery said in a 2007 interview
the last one i did gentleman director
steven norrington was given 85 million
dollars to make a movie in prague
but unfortunately he wasn't certified
before he started because he would have
been arrested for insanity
so we worked as well as we could and i
ended up being heavily involved in the
editing and trying to salvage
he was offered other roles after the
league of extraordinary gentlemen
including a part in the 4th indiana
jones film but he declined them all
because as he said on his official
website in the end retirement is just
too much fun
ultimately his final role was actually a
voice acting part in the 2012 animated
film
sir billy for the actor who originated
the role of james bond
won an oscar in 1988 was declared
sexiest man of the century by people in
1999
and was then knighted in 2000 the long
and happy retirement was well deserved
whatever health struggles he faced in
his final days will likely remain
private
what's most important to connery's fans
is the actor's long and impressive
career
and the legacy that he leaves behind